hey
kid can you can you uh remind me of what
it was
you had like some awesome uh
arrest report like like you got arrested
in
australia like yeah yeah
in australia
in 1999 i just went i i had
i saved up a little bit of money and i
figured i'd get there and i'd meet some
skaters and
and make friends with them and and you
know just kind of
see what happened because i always
wanted to go to australia so i went
there and sure enough i met
i met um skaters the first day i got
there i went to bondi beach and
that was kind of like the mecca of
australian skateboarding at the time
because there was the ramp on the beach
and and i made a bunch of friends and
and um then i i bought a bus ticket
where i could just travel up the coast
and stop in any town and then you could
get back on the bus and i got to this
place early beach
and um i was with a friend that i met on
the way and
i we got drunk one night and uh on red
bulls and whiskey
and um then i guess um he just he went
home eventually
and um i i think i was in a weird mood
that might that night or something
next thing i knew i i was being woken up
by a police officer in jail
he's like you want to get up now and i'm
you know i was like
i looked around i realized i'm in jail
he's like it's 11 o'clock
and i'm like what did i do and he's like
you got caught with a 14 year old girl
mate and i'm like
what he's like just kidding
you know you know then he told me like
what i did do was
i i like um i was in a
i ended up going into like a part of a a
resort that was being under construction
and um i broke this i think i got locked
in part of the building or stuck in it
and i broke through this giant like
safety glass window and i was smashing
at it wearing just
surf trunks no shoes nothing like that
and
the security was on the other side like
trying to like like mellow me out
but they couldn't get into me and but i
wouldn't mellow out and i smashed
through it and i jumped through and they
grabbed me
and um and then you know eventually the
eventually the police arrived in
you know they handed me over to the
police but in australia
they don't it's not like america where
they automatically handcuff you
they in australia they just put you in
the car
and um so they put me in the car they
should have handcuffed
me yeah they so according to police
report they put me in the police car and
then went to go talk to witnesses
while they were talking to witnesses i
kicked i kicked through the police car
window
and went to make my escape barefooted
but they quickly caught up with me
you know you know after a bit of after
some struggle
you know i was thrown in jail and then
so
how many that's like basically you know
how many the police report says so
so when i was talking to the cop he's
like um he told me what i did i was
he's like um i was like oh man i felt
terrible about it i'll go apologize to
the manager of the resort
and i apologize profusely to the police
and still i just had surf trunks on
those shoes
so then i had to walk a few miles into
town and on like
super hot asphalt and i went straight to
the resort um and i apologize to the
lady and she's like oh
i felt so bad we saw the footage of you
you know it was terrible
and i was like um
you know i i got i got the contacts but
i was never able to get it but i uh you
know in my mind at the time
i thought i thought it would come in
handy and i knew there was an idea
going on with big brother you know of
something you know what became jackass
but but anyway they didn't press charges
and the police
didn't press charges because like there
was like assaulting the police
destruction of property this and that
you know and you know
the police i i ended up winning their
hearts and they didn't press charges so
um i had to go to court like a few days
later and
in court i stood up in front of you know
there was other criminals there
like you know doing their cases so i was
explaining my situation i had a public
defender and
you know like i was telling my story and
like other like the other people like
in the courtroom were like laughing and
they were like basically i was they were
like well no one wants to press charges
if you pay for all your damages you know
you can go on your way and you know they
gave me like a year probation in
australia
and you know that the incident ended up
paying for itself in spades because i
wrote an article in big brother about it
i wrote an article in like maxim or fhm
about it
um i got to talk about it on different
tv shows i'm even talking about it now
like it was totally worth it yeah
dude